among the world's most advanced
economies it may be but the UK faces the
worst economic Outlook in a generation
people like Jasmine almond and her
husband Chris have found that two
full-time salaries no longer sustain a
family of four I can't believe you've
grown up so quickly the High Cost of
Living especially Child Care means that
Jasmine wasn't earning enough to pay the
nursery fees it worked out less
expensive to give up her job as a
teacher and care for daughter Karina
herself if I am a wife and a mother and
I have to do the right thing for our
household I am just going weak
to week we survive like that and
it's just life nowadays
on Wednesday Britain's Finance Minister
Jeremy Hunt will deliver his first
spring budget since taking the job last
Autumn Child Care will feature but must
take its place in a long queue
with public sector workers on strike
again even as the budget is announced in
an economy left reeling by covid brexit
and the war in Ukraine
I think one one area where there will be
kind of a lot of focus particularly on
his decisions is around public sector
pay and you know there's kind of a lot
of pressure around that with um with
strikes we're seeing Rising vacancies in
the public sector that's an area we will
see kind of quite a lot of pressure
and it's not just families looking for
help but whole communities in towns and
cities across the country where
political promises to level up
inequalities have not been met and slow
growth has led to calls by Business
Leaders for a clear strategy to attract
investment
take Coventry for instance here in the
West Midlands once a center of
manufacturing so important to Britain's
economy that Hitler's Air Force took
great care to bomb it into Oblivion
coventry's damaged Cathedral is
Testament to those Bleak times but at
the heart of the de-industrialized
Midlands it's a hollowed-out place even
now Jeremy Hunt will announce funding
for new low tax investment zones to try
and spur business and growth in areas
like this such as the scale of the task
that his budget will offer no quick fix
Jonah Hall Al Jazeera Coventry